j'espère de tout coeur que le président
va autoriser les petits commerçants à
réouvrir parce qu'ils ont vraiment
besoin de nous pour survivre j'espère
que les fêtes de noël auront bien lieu
en dépit du confinement
on attend de savoir quand est ce qu'on
va rouvrir quoi correctement qu'on
puisse gagner parce que bon mes patrons
il tire la gueule on se remet encore un
on parle on parle de fermeture malgré
toutes les aides malgré tout mais il
parle de fermeture quoi parce que il ya
plus d'argent corps et j'adorais me
girard voir il y aurait certainement là
la sortie limitée à un kilomètre
parce qu'on n'est pas dans la situation
du confinement du printemps il ya
beaucoup de voitures il ya beaucoup de
pollution et suivant l'endroit où on
habite moi j'habite pas loin d'un
périphérique et des commerces
en fait il n'ya pas vraiment l'endroit
où on peut faire un kilomètre en
vraiment respirant quoi je sais pas où
on va
je sais même pas si l'état sait où on va
ils le disent d'ailleurs eux mêmes
on sait pas où on va donc c'est au jour
le jour ça sent ça change tout le temps
je veux dire vivant et encore six mois
ne portait pas de masque
deux mois après on pèse 135 balle pour
avoir pour avoir une amende si on porte
pas de masque on en a marre en fait qui
devrait un peu les restaurants les pas
forcément les bars mais au moins les
restaurants et que les gens respectent
en fait juste les gestes barrières parce
qu'on n'a plus de lui on a plus de
villes et quartiers sont éteints peut
plus rien faire et surtout pour la
jeunesse en fait la jeunesse je pense on
prend un coup